because joeri de cockpit het sri lanka two
years ago the adoption storio we stolt
all his life's a de die fierce part i
discovered and biological mother of his
sister
was de friend and gis
identity road
ben johan identity fall to pieces
everything you have believed in for more
than thirty years as rond oria we tot is
not sure why why do we come from one
size tholen
like it noisy may have come from may be
for following and police van de  dutch
government
julia another adaptive uit de man in
financial compensation
to pay for cäcilie travel d en e test
and psychological support the whole zo
because we is stable in international die
in a database
to make it easier to my god optically met
the biological parents at dat  is a
human right that has been violated by johan
right sb violated and the door government
has been inserting into this dough let's
taste waal de new de dismal
practical intersection d i noo  it om huis
center frame for further investigation
th de handed out immigration pepers met
uit en die checks and balances dewi
clearer zelve victim of judgmental
adoption s5 claims of be than 100
victims hear that it is for my donia
for you that scruples automatically
considered adopting it  salt of my
pop country is a goodie questions
about the regions of the children
morelli out with hardly become clear
how a large-scale milk practical sat
damage de luis on the children
der that month before and sisters outside
article site of international and
dobson's a [ __ ]  banana it options
which shoot off the nori gate was
published this led to first race and the
man parachute sorry earplugs rolls the
design the petition loath the job
toby lift it in harm te the on you a
wimp not necessary such times
children should  be you run it and not
be kept in a foster care system and tired
form family to family and
no one take responsibilit  y of the
children
ret years old what kind of joe
reduction is familiar with house inner tubes is
still the pest solution of managers is
profit [ __ ] with mental health issues i
blame van is the cap I think
adoption
is the basics [ __ ] adoption is a selfies
choice for  people who want
children chad is not as for
the idea that you this to improve
the world and help chad is not
something angry with your wish is
claims you want to find is biological
mother who you first have been  looking
for him for dirty things you step
vaessen
al jazeera den bosch